Would you have voted for Donald Trump?
That's a hard question.
You know when it's funny,
because I've been Canada,
I actually went to,
I was invited out to a private club
the night of the American election by a
couple of Americans and there was a bunch
of Americans at this club and they did
a straw vote and you know,
I thought that what I probably would
have done when it came right down to it
because I had to vote hey in the struggle.
So that was a pretty
reasonable simulation.
I think what I would've done was walk
into the voting booth with the intention
of voting for Clinton and then at
the last minute gone to hell with it.
I'm not doing it and voted for trump.
I think that's what I would've done.
And I thought about it a lot afterwards.
I mean,
for the entire election virtually,
I thought,
well Clinton has the experience necessary
to at least keep the status quo in
motion,
you know?
So in some sense she was a conservative
choice because she'd been in politics
for so long.
So.
But then as the campaign continued
and she continued to beat the identity
politics drum louder and louder,
I became more and more concerned about
her political direction or ideological
direction.
And then I thought when I was thinking
about what happened to the United States,
I thought,
well,
here's what the Americans decided.
They decided that they
liked the unscripted,
impulsive,
live better than the scripted,
conniving,
unscripted,
impulsive lies of trump better than the
conniving scripted lines of Clinton.
It wasn't like the two
choices were so brilliant.
So I think I would have impulsively
voted for trump at the last moment.
I think so,
but I,
you know,
I can't be sure,
but it wouldn't have been
with the sense of delight.
I can tell you that.
So it would have been based on
like your sort of logically,
rationally you might have argued
Hillary Clinton is the conservative pick
because she's not going
to up in the system.
It's not going to be great,
but we know what we're
going to get with her.
But deep down viscerally,
maybe you feel like,
um,
what would that visceral sort
of sense of Ben for trauma?
Well,
it's a repugnance I,
I really do find identity
politics repugnant and I
don't use that term lightly.
I think that we're making a very
big mistake to retry belies our,
our social,
our social conceptual structure.
You know,
the,
the big advantage to being in the west
was that we live in a society where the
individual is sovereign and
some miraculous achievement
that we've managed that
both conceptually and practically.
And then to see the,
the left is pushing this I think.
I think the left is responsible for
this in large part the radical to read,
divide us among ethnic,
sexual or racial lines and
then other lines without.
And I think if a catastrophic
error and I just,
the Democrats just did far too much of
that and I wasn't happy at all that they
abandoned the working class.
You know,
like I have a fair bit of sympathy,
let's say for the working class.
Coming from a working class background,
having had a dozen or
more working class jobs.
Um,
and also some real appreciation
for working class people.
Like I liked working with my hands.
I've worked,
I've done a lot of renovation projects,
I've worked with a lot of contractors
and plumbers and carpenters and those
sorts of people and I felt that they
had been abandoned by the Democrats and
that,
that was,
that was a real betrayal,
a fundamental betrayal.
So,
and uh,
you know,
I know I'm not alone in those thoughts.
That's for sure.
I mean,
the same thing is happening in Canada.
The classic left wing,
the left wing in Canada has moved away
from its proper concentration on the
concerns of the,
of the working class poor.
Let's say I started planning this
intellectual identity politics game,
which I think is why do I
really find a detestable?
Yeah,
me too.
Me Too.
Look,
I think there's absolutely no doubt that
the left started this and that they're
to blame for it,
but I feel like Donald Trump,
so what conservatism and American
conservatism until recently said,
um,
identity politics is bad,
therefore we're not
going to play the game.
We're not going to do it.
And I believe that Donald
trump was a vote for,
hey,
we have to fight fire with fire.
If they're going to play it,
that's the big danger.
Well,
and that's one of the things that I've,
I mean,
I've saved most of my online vitriol,
let's say for the radical left because,
and I think the primary reason for that
is because of my academic background,
it's the route the radical left has,
has undue influence in academia and then
from academia into the broader world,
you know,
so it makes sense for me,
especially given the compelled speech
law in Canada to be primarily concerned
with the overreach of the radical left,
but it's not like I'm thrilled
with the identity Iranian,
right?
Because they're doing the same thing.
They're,
they're mode or their,
their strategy is different,
right?
Because the radical left
strategy is identify the
majority group and defeat them
with something like guilt.
But the radical right strategy is
well except the majority a virtue,
let's say and when,
when the fight,
but none of them,
neither of those
approaches are gonna work.
You know,
like even the,
even the white supremacist approach,
let's say.
I mean,
it's fatally flawed in a variety
of ways apart from its pure,
reprehensible realty.
It's like,
well,
who's white?
Exactly
like we're,
how do you draw these
distinctions is the problem.
Of course,
the intersection left has run into.
They run into the impossibility of making
group identifications with any degree
of accuracy,
but the same problem technically speaking,
be devil's attempts on the right.
It's like,
well,
what are the people who
inhabit northern India?
Are they white?
Like what?
Where exactly?
You're drawing the boundaries here.
Yeah.
Well,
it really matters all polling
way of looking at things.
I have the sense that that the problem
is that what the left wants to do today
is not to achieve parody.
They don't want women or minorities
to achieve parody and be equal.
They want them to be superior,
so in other words,
they believe in a zero sum game.
They don't believe we can grow the
pie and everybody be more prosperous.
They believed that there was zero,
zero ba winners,
the winners and losers,
and therefore they have to tear down.
Let's say men for example,
in the me too moment in
order to elevate women.
Yeah.
Well,
the zero sum problems,
a real one that bedeviled
the left forever.
You know,
and there there are constant claim
is well we live in a resource,
a resource
scarce environment and yeah,
there has to be winners and losers and
I don't think there's any evidence for
that at all.
Um,
and,
but the,
even if they're not out to
attain like an inversion,
so that the,
the,
the last become first,
let's say there are certainly not
paying any attention to the fact that
equality of outcome is impossible.
Impossible goal.
There's a measurement problems.
So the measurement problem
is well across what outcomes.
Exactly and I mean exactly because
these are very important issues.
You want people to be equal
across all possible outcomes.
Like where do you draw the borders?
Well that's a big problem like and,
and then the next problem is
who decides when they're equal,
how do you set up a system that isn't
the market system to decide when equality
has been attained?
So that's second insoluble problem.
And then third insoluble problem
is well across what groups?
Because I don't know how many
ethnic categories are used,
say in the US labor boards,
statistics and by the US government,
but it's something.
It's in the dozens,
like so you're going to
equate across all ethnicities.
Are you going to equate across all social,
like socioeconomic categories?
You're going to include the
infinite number of genders in that,
like their problem.
Technically the problem that they're
trying to solve can be solved technically
impossible to solve it apart from the
fact that it's also when it's put into
practice,
it's actually murderous equity doctrine,
I think is a murderous doctrine,
so,
but it's not so easy to
put your finger on why.